[Musique]
grand format aujourd'hui avec le
président du conseil départemental du
haut-rhin rémy vite on est ravis de vous
accueillir dans ce grand format vous
succéder rémy vite à brigitte klinkert
qui a été appelé par le gouvernement aux
castex d'abord ben comment vous avez
vécu sa nomination à l abri klinkert
bain
à vrai dire avec beaucoup de bonheur et
une grande satisfaction une joie aussi
que brigitte klinkert ses compétences
son travail son engagement et éthéré
père est reconnu par les plus hautes
instances de l'état
je crois que c'est tout à son honneur et
je salue vraiment cette mission
ministérielle qui est la sienne
alors vous êtes le nouveau président on
a les images là le jour de votre
domination c'était un moment important
c'est un moment important c'est un
moment important parce que je m'y
attendais pas moins non plus que ma
présidente soit nommé ministre et j'ai
vite compris qu'il fallait que je relève
le challenge pour refaire une nouvelle
période d'intérim d'avoir une ministre
aux affaires dans la perspective de la
cia
c'est un plus pour les alsaciens c'est
un atout et c'est une chance
je crois que brigitte avec sas à sa
capacité d'action sera vraiment notre
représentante au plan national et dans
le gouvernement pour pouvoir faire
avancer les petits problèmes qui peuvent
surgir au moment du démarrage de la sema
parce qu'il y aura forcément pour
remettre un peu d'huile dans les rouages
parce que même si juridiquement et
administrativement les choses ont été
prévus dans le fonctionnement proprement
dit il y aura forcément parfois des
choses à arranger des angles à arrondir
vous êtes président jusqu'au 1er janvier
oui quels sont les grands enjeux pour et
militants ben c'est comme on l'a dit
préparé cette cea dans de bonnes
conditions avec mon homme au monologue
bas rhinois est donc de faire en sorte
que l'on peut tout de suite au 2 janvier
être opérationnel au point de vue de la
cia
quelle qu'elle soit que les problèmes de
gouvernance de gestion de fonctionnement
et pu être réfléchie et résolues pour
que l'on puisse être pratiquement tout
de suite dans l'action dès le 2 janvier
que se passera-t-il pour vous à partir
du 1er janvier il y aura plus de
présidence du tout il faudra attendre le
mois de mars et l'élection
d'abord on sait pas qui sera président
au 1er janvier c'est la première
question même si mon collègue bas
rhinois a déjà laissé entendre qu'il ne
sera je crois que ça ça fait aussi
partie des discussions qu'on aura à voir
sur les trois mois qui viennent c'est à
nous justement de faire en sorte que
cette collectivité européenne d'alsace
prennent je dirais la bonne en vol le
bon envol soit mise sur de bons rails
dès le départ pour qu'au moment du
renouvellement fin mars prochain la
nouvelle assemblée puisse fonctionner
burgert prône pour une gouvernance qui
tournerait saint frédéric bierry a dit
qu'il ne le souhaitait pas quelle est
votre position réduite
j'entends j'entends la position de
frédéric berry je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de
justement de ces discussions
c'est aussi à l'assemblée qui sera élu
en mars qu'il appartiendra de se
positionner du président da présidence
de ce moment-là de s'exprimer sur le
sujet et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui viendra au moment où il faudra
et la question se posera où se posera
pas nous verrons sur les sujets
polémiques il est aussi le siège
eric straumann récemment au micro
d'alsace 20 disait qu'il aimerait que la
cea et son siège à colmar
frédéric bierry pouces égal à lui pour
ce soit strasbourg votre opposition
ben moi c'est pareil je reste je
souhaite que ce soit à colmar parce que
ce sera le premier signe d'une
gouvernance partagée entre un président
qui pourrait être d'origine bas-rhinoise
avec un siège plutôt rhinois se seraient
déjà les premiers signes d'un équilibre
territorial
maintenant le siège n'est peut-être pas
fondamental non plus un moment donné
c'est pas ça qui doit empêcher
de continuer je dirais les échanges et
le partage de cette gouvernance moi je
pense que au delà du siège c'est de
rester une collectivité de proximité
d'être inventive et créative on a la
chance d'avoir une nouvelle collectivité
qui va se créer et qu'ils puissent
s'ouvrir à vraiment à ce que les
territoires dans leur diversité puisse
être représentée et surtout compris
nouvelle le compétences puisque y aura
les routes nationales qui rentreront
dans le dans le giron de la cea il ya
les compétences transfrontalière des 2 c
sur lequel vous travaillez les gens
c'est tous les jours que les alsaciens
les alsaciennes franchissent la
frontière pour les besoins de leur
travail
mais au-delà de cela le transfrontalier
c'est aussi l'économie certes mais c'est
le tourisme c'est les transports ce sont
plein d'autres sujets qui méritent
d'être pris en compte comme par exemple
fessenheim c'est aussi une partie futur
du territoire futur de fessenheim et
l'avenir de fessenheim passe aussi par
une participation transfrontalière et
puis elle bilinguisme qui est qui et je
dirai la pièce maîtresse je crois que on
a la chance avec ces nouvelles
compétences de passer du dû parler
europe à l'acte européen c'est-à-dire de
traduire dans des actes ce que l'on dit
depuis longtemps à tous les niveaux de
montrer que dans une région comme
l'alsace
on peut vraiment mettre en pratique
cette notion d'europe
je vais pas répondu à votre question sur
les routes
effectivement les routes nationales et
les autoroutes non concédées bon nous
être transféré à partir du 2 janvier
on a envisagé de mettre en place une
redevance pour
pour le trafic des poids lourds de
transit mais il va falloir engager une
large concertation avec le monde
économique et avec les entreprises de
transport alsacienne pour que je dirais
la démarche soit bien compris c'est bien
réfléchi c'est c'est une démarche qui
peut être importante pour le respect de
l'environnement
moins de poids lourds sur nos routes et
puis qui peut être très importante pour
la sécurité routière de nos usagers
remet vite on va rappeler quand même que
vous aviez été le plus jeune maire à
l'époque un endroit pas citer l'année
mais vous aviez 21 ans et ardent
défenseur de la ruralité de cette
proximité là oui j'étais maire alain
tient en un peu presque par hasard
ma première adjointe était déjà une
femme donc c'est aussi démontré qu avant
la loi sur la parité
on a su vraiment avancer même dans un
petit village comme altenach on a pu
être un peu dans la modernité avant leur
ruralité hui je suis défenseur de la
ruralité mais pas contre l'urbain je
pense honnêtement que le rural et
l'urbain doivent cohabiter sont
complémentaires et je pense c'est ça la
spécificité justement de l'alsace c'est
ça la spécificité du haut-rhin et du
bas-rhin de faire en sorte que nos
territoires soient vraiment prise en
compte dans leur spécificité